template literals template literals are
string literals allowing embedded
expressions you can use multi-line
strings and string interpolation
features with them template literals are
enclosed by this bag the backtick with
the back that key is right next to the
one on the keyboard first I want to show
you multi-line strings now you can see
these this is on two different lines in
the console normally it you can't just
put extra lines and have it make a new
line in the console that put a few more
lines like as you can see it's gonna put
a lot of lines in between these two
lines another thing you can do with
template literals are is expression
interpolation let me give you an example
of that so if I run this you can see
it's the expression interpolation
happens with these symbols there's a
dollar sign and then these squiggly
brackets and and anything inside the
dollar sign the squiggly brackets is
going to evaluate and put the answer
right into your string same with right
over here and you can see that it adds a
plus B Phi plus Inc we get the 15 over
here and that does also two times a plus
B over here to get the 20 you can still
use the the newline just like you would
do in a regular string you don't have to
give it a newline but that would work if
I just put new a new line just like that
you can see it's gonna be exactly the
same the next thing I want to talk to
you about is tagged template literals
this is basically passing a template
literal into a function let me show you
so I have my function written and now
I'm going to pass a template literal
into that function this function is
called tag but it doesn't matter what
the function is called and let me run
that so you can see the last two lines
here is what happens from the this tag
template literal example it's going to
run the function tag and it's going to
input input this tip template literal
all the strings go into this strings
array and the values go into the value
array if you have dot that dot that just
means a a an array here so the strings
you can see our hello there's also so
you can see the hello here and then
world right there is right here in the
in the console and then there's nothing
right between this last expression and
the back tick there's nothing there so
that's shown in the console with an
empty string now you can see the values
in the console 15 and 50 well it passes
in the expressions as the values so this
skips passed in as 15 because 5 plus 10
is 15 and then this gets passed in as 50
so it it goes through the whole template
literal first it takes out the strings
and then it takes out the the values as
as the expressions in this function I
had returned GS nuggets but it's not
we're not doing anything with that so we
can do this if we consult log this and
then we run this you can see that it's
gonna print print J's nuggets at the end
now I want to show you a more
complicated way of using tag template
literals ok this code I copied right
from the Mozilla developer Network page
on template literals and this code right
here and I just want to walk you through
it this is the function and we're gonna
have this we're going to assign this
variable down here t1 closure to
this the function template and we're
gonna pass in this template literal here
I'm going to uncomment out this console
dot log and we're gonna run this we're
gonna look at the very bottom where it
says yay so when we passed in we called
the t1 variable and we passed in the
letters wine a it print printed yay
let's walk through why that actually
happened in our previous example of the
tag template literals we returned a
string but you don't have to return a
string because in this function we
actually return a function the strings
and the keys from the that we pass into
the original function are right here so
we're passing in this template literal
that becomes they gets broken into the
strings and the keys then we are down
here we're calling the t1 closure
variable and we're passing the Y in the
a into the function that's being
returned by the template one way to help
you understand this better is we're
going to console dot log the strings
here and the keys and then comment out
this and I'm going to run it and you can
see at the bottom the strings here where
you console that lock the strings that's
blank blank string blank string
exclamation Park exclamation point
because there's it gives you a blank
string because there's nothing between
these these expressions in the template
literal and then we have the exclamation
point at the end and then it's 0 1 0
this what we get when we pass in these
expressions 0 1 0 that's the keys from
here so now we're going to return this
this function and the values from this
function come from the Y and the a so
let's go through this VAR dick equals
values so we're going
to the values array and we're finding
this index values dot length minus 1 so
that's gonna be the last item in the
values array so remember the values
array is why a and the last value is a
so we now have our result equals an
array C it's surrounded by these
brackets and inside the array array
we're gonna access this other array the
strings array which is right over here
if you look in the console dot log the
array at index 0 is nothing so the
result is going to currently equal
nothing now Keys dot for each so we're
going to loop through each of the keys
now remember the keys if you look at the
console the keys arrayed are 0 1 0 for
each key we're on the the first key 0
VAR value equals number that is integer
key so it's 0 number yes it is a number
and in fact 0 1 0 those are all numbers
so this is a ternary operator if the it
is a number and all these are numbers
we're gonna do the first thing before
the colon if they weren't a number we do
the second thing if you look at down at
line 43 at one of these examples we have
something that's not a number but for
this example all of our numbers so we
are going to go to the values array and
go to the index of the key remember the
values array is right here Y a and we
have the index the first the first key
is 0 so that would be Y and this is
result that pushed the value and that
values of Y or Y and we're also going to
push the strings array I plus 1 so I is
0 so that b1 the strings array is red it
is here 0 plus 1 is going to be it still
an empty string so it's not going to
push anything so this is going to just
push Y now I'm going to go through it
again and we're going to use the next
key which is 1 so the next key 1 is
going to bring up the a here and when it
does result that puts out
it's gonna push the a in here and that's
going to go through a third time we have
the key zero which is going to go back
to the Y and this time we're gonna push
the Y and when we go to strings I plus
one
well I plus one is going to be two plus
one which is going to be three so this
is the strings array this time it's not
going to push on an empty string it's
going to push on the exclamation point
at the very end and then return results
dot join so we have an array which is
just Y a Y estimation points and when we
join each item in the array it's going
to put on to one string and that's how
we get Y a for this string at the end
now if i uncomment out these and run
this you can see that this is going to
do that it's gonna go through the same
thing but it's gonna eventually get to
this hello world and if you want to go
through individually and see how that
all works out you can thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes check
the description for links to more
information please subscribe and
remember use your code for good